welcome back everyone to new coffee
break here on my channel from learning
as you know i am heinrich and on my
channel i try to help you to become
successful in the first years of your
career and today i'm very excited about
this episode because it is going to be
an episode that is absolutely packed
with value i have anthony here with me
today a colleague of me at building
radar welcome anthony good to be here
thanks for having me awesome and anthony
is not just any colleague but he is our
head of product he's actually based in
the london office we have a second
dependence there in london and he's
visiting this week here in munich so i
thought what better opportunity can
there be to just do this together
because i think your story is very very
interesting going to dive into that in a
moment what this episode is going to be
all about is three main points
first we are very much looking to
explore the whole motivation of doing an
mba why should you do an mba why
shouldn't you maybe do an mba so this
whole idea of the reasoning to pursue it
and why you're the perfect person for
that let's talk about this in a moment
second we're also going to talk about
well maybe in the end of the day you
might decide not to pursue it what other
opportunities are there if you decide
against the mba and why it might be a
good decision to then also not do it in
the end and then last but not least
we're going to talk about transitioning
from an engineering role
to
a tech role to a large tech company at
any of these farm companies and so on
anthony but maybe just in in a nutshell
why are you the perfect person to talk
about these things here right now i
guess um it was it was very funny story
when you joined the company i'd only not
long been here myself
uh found out that you had done a mba at
insead in fact the class that i was
supposed to join
and for some of the reasons we're going
today uh why i didn't take the insead
route but yeah hopefully i've got some
interesting insights it was very
difficult decision for me
maybe i can kind of share that with some
of the viewers of the channel that might
help inform some of the hard decisions
they might need to make about their
career development
so let's just unpack that what you said
right so anthony you applied to insert
so you did all the things that are
necessary to apply for an mba which is i
mean quite a lot right so doing an mba
doing all the preparation reworking even
told me that you did a cfa level one
just to prep for that you applied you
got in you got the offer you actually
already accepted the offer right you pay
the deposit
paid that how much was that if you
mentioned 7 000 euros is it 7 000 euros
so you paid all that and then you
decided and then not to do it but let's
dive into that because i think that's
very interesting maybe you can share a
little bit just more about your
background what did you do before all of
this and what was your initial
motivation to pursue it why did you
decide that yes actually it would be a
great idea for me personally to do an
mba
yeah so i started off i studied civil
engineering at university
joined a structural engineering company
it's very predictable career path you
know spent my entire career there
i was designing skyscrapers
moved out to china more responsibility i
was quite ambitious
and it started to occur to me that um
how did i really kind of get to the next
level i started to look at some of the
the senior leaders
around me
some of the developer companies that we
were working with and i started to spot
this mba after many of their kind of
names in the brochures and things like
that that was the first time i really
started thinking about uh an mba
um the more i dug into it the more i
kind of reflected on what i wanted to do
with my own career was actually moving
to technology
i was reading a lot of stuff in the news
i think started to wonder hang on a
second what if ai starts designing
buildings then what am i going to do
still early in my career you had this
kind of like existential threat moment
and figured out that yeah if somebody
was going to disrupt my industry then
i'd be the one doing it
and that's kind of where led me to look
at considering an mba to make that
career transition into the tech sector
you said one thing that i think is very
interesting and i know that also just in
the firm learning community there's
always some debate also in the comments
if i talk about these things you said
that you know you looked at your senior
management your leadership many people
had mbas there
what is your reflection that how
important is it in a more traditional
company which i understand that was your
career at that time
how important is it still to have an mba
and to what extent is your perception
that this depends maybe also just on the
region or can just shed some light into
that yeah that's a really good question
um
i think in hindsight i i didn't really
understand why
these senior people had mbas it was more
like a pattern that i'd spotted which
kind of led me down you know the path of
exploring an mba i wouldn't even say
that i
knew how an mba would get me to that
role
i just felt like it was an avenue i
needed to explore and maybe in hindsight
not everybody in a senior leadership
position has an mba and so there are
obviously other paths to get there
and i think yeah the mba was really an
opportunity for me to take some time
with like-minded ambitious individuals
to find out what i actually really want
to do my career long term
and so then this was the journey you
decided to apply
why did you go for insat what was
appealing for you for this specific
program
yeah insead um i think one of the i mean
a big plus point obviously it's a one
year program uh when you're thinking
about opportunity costs i was already
you know into my career
um
i guess the second thing though actually
is that um
i i've since making that decision lived
in america for a few years and i've kind
of
really seen a different side to america
but maybe as somebody not being born in
america had this kind of
oh you know american mba schools they're
only aware of american mba schools and
being a european at heart i'm gonna go
to the european one uh and so insead was
high in the ranking but obviously also
being in asia at the time
uh insead having that singapore campus
was a really big plus point
for me personally so
so you apply to instead and i mean i
think i would share a similar rationale
right so from my humble perspective why
might ncr be a good choice
first if you don't see your future in
the us because i think indeed if you aim
to work in the u.s um the us quotes will
always have a better standing a better
reputation i think that's one important
consideration
second is that it's a one-year program
right so if you think about roi of
course the one thing is that you invest
twice the time
so you have twice the cost in terms of
tuition living costs but also you have
two years of foregone salary right which
i think many people sometimes forget uh
to include in the calculation so the ri
might be nice and then of course outside
the u.s i think insead maybe closed
whale london business school and so on
surely the number one program
so you apply it you even got in can you
just walk us through this
application process so what were all the
things that you did for that and how did
that feel like for you or someone coming
from a an engineering background it was
really hard
to be quite frank um and i think
actually looking at one of your recent
videos in fact you were talking about um
this kind of over like the the danger of
over fixating on a very singular goal
and i decided i'd internalize that it
was insead or nothing for various
factors
um
it's really tough to get those gmat
scores uh i i got something that i
thought might scrape me in i spoke to
the admissions
officer and she said if you think you
can do better you should maybe try again
and i went and gave another shot
the obviously the language you know the
additional language interview that was a
big challenge
but
yeah i just i
just thinking back to those feelings
like waiting for the decision to come
back wondering whether my gmat score was
enough
it really felt at that time that if i
didn't get offered a place i wouldn't
have known what to have done next uh it
would have been i feel like such a big
disappointment i really didn't have a
backup plan at that time and in
retrospect it was it was foolish i think
um to think like that what would you do
differently if you would face the
situation again today
i think i needed to i i was ultimately
pursuing an mba for a specific outcome
and i knew what the outcome was i wanted
to get from the engineering sector into
the tech sector and i i think i'd just
become lost in the forums
and you know the process to think that
an mba was the only mechanism to get to
where i wanted to go
and the reality was it just simply
wasn't true
which i later found out
and it's interesting and let's talk
about that in a moment as
as well i mean you talked about the gmat
in beginning we quickly talked about
this deposit that you even needed to pay
i mean you were really fully committed
and you even joined i mean you showed me
some photos of pre-mba trips right that
you joined i mean maybe just talk a
little bit about that so how did that
work what did you do there that was
fantastic so i was living in shanghai at
the time
um i was i think i was in the very first
cohort uh accepted and so
the the school puts us in touch with the
other people that were accepted in our
cities and so lots of great nights out
with all of the uh the shanghai insead
candidates um
and it was this kind of like camaraderie
that we were already developing we're
all so excited for where we were going
to be next year
yeah it makes me really actually think
about that's probably the thing that
makes me really realize what perhaps i
missed out on by not actually going
going that route but um yeah that was
really kind of fabulous time uh insead
were fantastic in terms of um inviting
us on campus for like us i think it's
like a short weekend where you could
kind of really kind of get it get a
taste for what it was going to be like i
think that really helped me mentally
prepare for what it was going to
be like but uh yeah in some cases you're
waiting maybe nine months for the
program to start that's a
really exciting time and yeah it was
trying to productively invest that
excitement to make sure that you know i
was going to be as successful as
possible in the program started
that that sounds great right and you did
all that you mentally prepared you
visited the campus you joined the
pre-mba trips but still then there was
the point where you said
for me at this point in time it's not
the right decision and again can you
unpack this as well what led you to that
realization yeah so it was very much
unexpected um i was again i guess with
all of that energy getting ready for the
program i really started looking into
applying for um
internship roles uh because i didn't
have any tech experience um
from my careers to date i felt like an
internship would really kind of help me
get that first job after the program
finished and so i
blindly approached
this particular company i discovered
through the news
which was a google x spin out company
involved with automation of design in
the architecture space it was it had my
name written all over it
i reached out to them once no response
um
waited a couple months gave another shot
in the dark and amazingly somebody got
back to me
um and that essentially started a series
of interviews
with that company i did an on-site
interview as well
um
and surprisingly i just i wasn't
expecting it
they offered me a full-time role
and i was only asking for an internship
i think startup startups they have a
different
kind of um time frame of reference than
maybe the bigger companies
and they were like
look you know we need you now like uh
and so
you know i was saying well can i go and
do this
program first and come back in a year
and then start up might not be around in
a year or we might have been doing
something else in a year and so i really
felt like it was a now and ever
opportunity
and um
yeah it was it was very difficult to
think about all of things that i would
have missed out on uh going to insead
the access to like a lifetime
network
um you know just the strengthening of my
my cv
but at the same time i already had this
option here to achieve my objective
which was to transition into the tech
industry move to san francisco move to
the silicon valley right really get all
these impressions exactly exactly and uh
you know obviously there was the 7 000
euro down payment and all of the
expectations i'd set with my friends and
my now wife that this is what i was
going to do for a year um but in the end
i think i just had to be honest with
myself that i was doing the mba for this
particular outcome and here i had a
window of opportunity for this outcome
um and i and i had to take it
and just for the uninitiated i mean
google x is
part of alphabet right so google it's
this incubator where they spin off new
innovative businesses and you had then
the opportunity to join one of them so
indeed you exactly like the outcome that
you wanted to get through the mba
suddenly was presented to you just like
that just by you taking the courage uh
to apply right and
i'm not like why didn't you apply
already before i mean that's the obvious
question right like why did you already
apply a you earlier before you even
started applying to the nba it's it's a
really good question there was the
reality is there was nothing stopping me
from doing that
i think
again in retrospect i like to think that
doing an mba
is a socially acceptable reason to
totally change your trajectory
and i don't know why you know maybe that
fear that in in the future somebody's
going to look at your cv and there'll be
some career transition that maybe
doesn't make sense but um
yeah
i think the mba was the thing that
really was making me reflect
and
as a result gave me the time and maybe
motivation to think about what i really
wanted to do and then start taking those
actions i should have just taken earlier
earlier i think that's fair right and at
least and i mean you were maybe not
lucky probably due to your abilities and
skills right so you were able to get
that internship also without the nba or
this position actually
for many people that were also in my
cohort or in the core that both of us
would have been part of um these types
of career transition surely were one of
the main motivations to do mbas and
there were always these three things
that people talked about so transitions
in regards to geography in regards to
industry or in regards to function this
is what what many many people were
looking after so doing a transition at
least in one of these areas if not in
two or even all three
um and for many it worked for some
probably also they didn't reach the
goalpost mba
and this was i think indeed also one of
the points i tried to make in this other
video the other week
i think just just not very clever right
so join me just for this one purpose we
knew i think i had had a broader
perspective it's not that you wanted to
join just this one specific company but
rather a sector an industry i think
that's probably fair um but some people
are just also so tied up on some of
these other elements that just doesn't
make sense
um but yeah so it's i think a very bold
decision right to just say i cut the
ties i i invested all of this i did all
this and i just do take the other route
um if you reflect on that today
how do you perceive all of this to play
it out now in the end i mean was that
the right decision at the time it's
i
i guess i'll never know i think that's
the reality i i don't have any regrets
maybe if i had chosen the insead path
i don't know i don't know how my life
could have been different but
i think it was again the reason why we
you know
so
fantastic when you joined the company
was like wow maybe if i had gone the
ncaa route i would have ended up back
here with heinrich anyway like maybe
these different paths take you to the
same destination
and um
yeah i just think that that would again
it was such a difficult decision at the
time
i really wasn't sure which
route was going to have the highest
payoff long term in my career i think
that i
went for the short-term
opportunity versus the long-term uh
gains that you almost guaranteed get
with that mba program and the brand
recognition and the access to the
community but um
again it was a it was a means to an end
and
that would seem like there was a
shortcut to the end that had to take
let's maybe as a third part of this of
this video talk about just in general
this transition from engineering to tech
because i mean again just also reading
comments and listening to many of you
guys out there i know that many of you
also come from a technical background so
rather than sense of engineering than
the tech
industry and actually would love to do
this transition um do you have any
advice or maybe also just reflections on
your journey to share
what people can do so an mba can be an
option i think this is one of the
learnings but doesn't need to be an
option so what is your take on this on
succeeding in this transition
i think the reality is that um the tech
sector didn't exist
maybe 15 20 years ago in the form that
it exists today and so it wasn't like
there were
a million people all studying
tech at university and now they all work
in the tech sector uh they came from
other programs like finance or
traditional engineering programs
but also creative functions as well and
so
um
yeah i think i had it in my head that i
had studied software engineering and
that it was too late already and
therefore i could never get a seat you
know in the tech sector but uh yeah
actually i'm really astonished at the
variety of backgrounds that
people have coming into the into the
tech sector and also the realization
that not everybody a tech company
writes software uh there's people like
like yourself involved with you know how
do we market and sell the product um
what i do now like how do we decide what
to even build
um
i think coming from an engineering
background is a big plus point um
in the tech sector because at the end of
the day you are working with software
engineers and having that engineering
background being able to
empathize with the realities of building
anything
uh put me in a relatively strong
position
but also like the rise of b2b
uh software company companies having a
specific industry background and
bringing that knowledge of the
construction sector which i had into a
tech company helped us build new tech
products for the construction sector and
so yeah in a way it could actually
be a golden ticket
to get in
and actually if you would be interested
to join a tech company as well we here
at buildingradar we are currently hiring
there's several open positions we will
leave a job posting links to that in the
video description so feel free to check
it out both actually for your team and
also for our business team here um
there's one key hire at the moment that
we're looking for that we are calling a
revenue engineer and no worries this
does nothing have to do with engineering
so you don't need to be an engineer it's
more a consulting business type of role
where we work together closely first of
all with us as a senior leadership here
at building radar but also with some of
our most senior clients most important
clients and you would have a key part in
reshaping the direction of our company
with that
so if you would be interested we would
love to get your applications for that
just two requirements specifically for
the revenue engineer role you would need
to be based in munich and you would need
to be able to speak german
anthony big big thanks for this little
conversation we had also i just learned
a couple of new points that also didn't
know about you which was i think quite
fantastic
appreciate your time thank you so much
and let's see i think we have lots of
other topics to potentially explore in
the future maybe also about what it's
like to be a chief product officer or
things like that so let's see if there's
maybe a episode two with anthony maybe
also let us know in the comments if you
would be interested in that
um
thank you
as always if you took any value out of
this video at all smash the like button
for the youtube algorithm and subscribe
to stay up to date on all the content a
big big thanks to the members of from
learning for your support very much
appreciate it my name is heinrich i
release weekly videos here on the
channel next one you will see next
saturday so until then all the best to
you all and bye-bye thank you